i am going to be interviewing jj watt as
part of the
sloan sports uh the sport a sloan mit
sports business conference that is going
down this weekend
on a man who actually helps put it
together uh and crafts it as well as he
does putting a basketball team together
daryl mori the philadelphia 76ers here
on the rich eisen show how are you daryl
rich thanks for having me on i'm gonna
rub scott drew's head to
try and get that championship vibe so
you know what i i had a chat with him he
seems like uh he's walking on air
cloud nine man that's what it is i'm
happy yeah he's he's been
i think he's been at it about 20 years
like me so it gives me hope
maybe this is the year so how does a a
an nba executive like yourself watch
march madness how do you
take it in daryl i mean
you take it in a little bit like a fan
it's hard not to
get into the drama especially the close
games at the same time
you're thinking about your own team and
saying huh could this guy fit in could
that guy fit in and
i found it as you know because i've had
some good teams and some not as good
teams when when your team's worse the
players of the tournament seem better
and when the the team is better like we
have a great team now i'm like well
that guy could never guard joel embiid
so i can't use him you know
so that's interesting well joel
how's he doing that that's that is that
the world's largest knee brace
i don't know if were you ever a round of
yao ever needed one i mean that that
looks like
i i've been what do you think i've been
through a lot of uh seven-footer
you know injuries it turns out once you
get reached seven feet
things start to not uh evolution didn't
anticipate that very well so he
generally have some
things to deal with but uh we're excited
joel's back
looks like as good as ever you know as
he
led us to victory versus the celtics he
he takes special
special joy in beating the celtics well
here you are
um tied uh best record in the eastern
conference as you and i are sitting here
uh daryl um how well positioned do you
think your team is
right now for the run that you hope to
achieve with doc
and this squad very good i mean we'd
like to hold on to
first um i do think the the one seed
will probably have a little bit
easier of a pass this year hopefully um
that second round being important and
then the home court i think
i think us in milwaukee and brooklyn are
all pretty evenly matched
as shown by a records role within like a
game or so of each other
so it could come down to home court and
you know usually comes down to the big
studs
you know joelle and tobias and ben for
us
and the stars on the others who plays
the best and so
um just a couple more questions here
before we turn to the
15th annual mit sloan sports analytics
conference that
i'll be taking part in here uh later on
this week is
so when you're talking about home court
obviously being
not having to travel and certainly the
way the conditions are right now
that that's important but um is there a
conversation about
um if more you know where we're just a
few days away from
um apparently any person over the age
of i guess 16 depending on the vaccine
to get it is there a conversation going
on in the nba right now daryl about
vaccinating as many players as possible
and then maybe
having the arenas open up and things
becoming a little bit more
back to normal in time for the playoffs
have you already heard that
type of conversation yeah no it's it's
great because it's spring and
everything's new and you know our arena
is at i think
20 and uh probably increasing
hopefully in the not too near future and
you know our uh our staff and players
the ones that qualify
have been able to get get the vaccine
um you know in uh in our area and
yeah we're we're moving full speed ahead
and you know it's been
been amazing the the roll out and
you know it does feel like things are
hopefully going to be
closer to normal i think all of us will
always be wary
going forward forever in our lives but
closer to normal
um down the road all right have you
heard about any pushback maybe from
players about getting vaccinated
in the nba at all daryl well i think
it's it's something that's a personal
choice for everyone and i think
uh you know the the majority of
our staff and players have have chosen
to do it as myself
president of basketball operations of
the philadelphia 76ers daryl murray here
on the rich eisen show
okay daryl i guess uh on thursday uh
at the uh sloane sports analytics
conference um
i'm gonna i'm gonna have at it with jj
watt you you put you and your crack team
put this together
um what do you want out of this thing
with me and jake
oh and uh i've talked to jj for years
okay to come because obviously he's he's
such a
icon and what he's done both on and
off and i would turn to you rich you're
more of a football expert to me my sense
was that you could argue for j.j watt
being the league mvp
for two or three seasons out of his
career so it's pretty
pretty exciting to have him and and what
he means and uh when we
when uh when we when we got him i knew
we had to get the best person to talk to
him so
no i appreciate that but my concern is
like my concern is
about you know analytics here daryl um
and i'll be honest with you par part of
it is you know this is not
my area of expertise number one and
number two
to be very honest with you daryl i'm
concerned that you know once i get
through
maybe the third uh round of questions i
get through
you know the first two uh times through
the order of questions i'm gonna get
removed
because you're concerned based on the
analytics that i might
run out of questions towards the end and
um i might not be looking over my
shoulder the entire time
daryl is that is that don't worry the
people who tune in aren't shy
well first off you're a professional
interviewer so i'm guessing you could
probably do five hours
but you're being modest but on top of
that those who
you know are at the conference and and
then have a ticket
you know they're going to be able to
chat submit questions so you won't be
short of questions it'll be more
it'll be more like you having to to to
sift through them and i'm sure
you know we got a pro for a reason okay
so there's no interview above
replacement
number there's no iar or anything like
that
that that's going to be applied to me
mid-interview and then all of a sudden i
get the hook like that's not happening
is what you're saying we like the gunk
show that actually i love that idea
and we're definitely doing that going
forward but we won't do it to you
tomorrow without you
we wouldn't do that okay i'm just i love
the idea of being able to gong off
like uh both the presenter and the
moderator we we've had some panels
in the past where uh where we could do
it one year
one year one of the panelists gone
themselves off and went full
the movie naked gun and after about five
minutes just
ran off stage but left his mic hot as he
was
yelling through the halls bathroom
emergency bathroom
are you serious who is
who was that it was on the poker panel
it was on the poker panel
poker hellmuth
don't do that don't do it in the middle
of it yeah i gotta
jj you take over for a bit no no no it's
all on zoom anyway so
uh boy you got elton brando up here
how'd that happen
uh let me look through other people who
are here um
jonathan kraft and and kevin demoff so
you got some people up the flow chart
in the nfl like what do you did you
start this
from the beginning or did you come in in
the in the first 15 or
or what's your history with this yeah no
it was it was myself and jessica gilman
who's that speaking of jonathan gruff
she's
worked for the patriots and the crafts
yeah there she is has her own spin-off
company called kager
she and i started in 2006 and
uh it's gotten bigger gotten bigger
every uh every
year so yeah as you know as someone that
you know
seen the evolution in every sport and
the nfl even more
you know it's just something that keeps
getting bigger and bigger
and uh you know i think the the one
in the nfl that's that's definitely
talked a lot about it the conference in
recent years is that
people don't understand why anyone runs
the ball at all anymore it should just
be
passes every down essentially so what
yeah
give me just a real quick let's just
cross streams here a little bit here
so what what what is you know the the
number one
nfl analytic that you've noticed or has
discussed
that you've heard being discussed that
uh
that you think is gonna get bigger and
more uh prevalent uh
the conversation of when to go for two
even if you're
up eight rather than kicking that extra
point or you're down 14 you go for two
as soon as you get
your score forget about momentum if you
missed the two you're still down eight
you
you know chasing points and things of
that nature what what what about that
one
yeah i think it's uh if you don't mind
i'll give a little bit of an overview
i think the nba is like 10 years behind
baseball you know baseball sort of led
the charge here and i think the nfl is
about 10 years behind the nba
and 20 years behind baseball in terms of
incorporating in the nfl the first
places where you saw it was in
player contracts because the hard cap
really
forced teams to be you know really smart
and obviously the patriots were one of
the
one of the teams that was quite a bit
ahead and valuing draft picks and things
like that
and it's only recently that you've seen
it move to on the field
and the past it's not quite the big
impact that uh three you know shooting
more threes has been in the nba but
the past just on average again on
average you still would run i was joking
before but
on average the pass is something that
generally leads to
a higher point total on per drive you
know no matter what yard line you
well not no matter what on most yard
lines you you start on
and so that's that's a big one just the
slow increase in passing in the
nfl is similar to the increase in
three-point shooting
in the nba and then you get down into
the stuff you're talking about which is
really important the tactical stuff you
know
go on fourth down go for two uh wind
onsite kick
all that stuff has has evolved and you
know you see teams that are
you know good amount ahead of other
teams on that i think the ravens are one
of those teams right now
well and daryl um you know
not to get awkward the day before i'm
doing this
highly important uh interview uh on
behalf of your conference
uh with j.j watt but i'm going to do it
i'm still going to go through with it
daryl
um despite you know the fact that i
have subsequently found out that one of
the
panels at your conference is entitled
say goodbye
to the 40-yard dash the future of nfl
roster building
i you know it's hard not to take it
personally i'll be very honest with you
kevin clark of the ringers uh thank you
for not asking me to
to moderate that panel but you got um
you got nick casario and kevin demoff to
talk about this among others
what gives is my just well we are
going to get approval from your
marketing team but we the logo for that
panel is your iconic logo with a big
red x through it you know so that oh my
gosh
yes other than that what are you talking
about i'm expecting a letter from your
lawyers in a few hours
yes season desists daryl cease and
desist
come on man i mean is that really what's
coming
for the future of development and
putting a roster together in the nfl
the 40-yard dash is history i haven't
been part of the planet for that panel
my guess is what they're focused on is
is what are the key drivers for
evaluating draft picks and
my my hypothesis is that the casario and
demo for
gonna say that the fortier dash probably
isn't isn't the most indicative which
gives hope for your
nfl career rich
to be a great draft pick yeah by the way
your
your team has been phenomenal putting
this all together um
the one thing i just asked is like just
you got to help me out
with data and how you wanted to be put
in there and i guess for
for jj watt the data that i have is that
about herniated discs and torn left
pectoral muscles about coming back and
what the average is and what the
percentage of coming back and all and
recovery and full-time recovery
i mean so so this analytical data
actually helps with
with health and safety as well is what
you're saying
absolutely yeah no it's it's it's a big
area and i'm sure you have
ceo better contacts in the nfl than i do
so sure
no don't say i don't know about that
daryl i don't know about that
people knock on you well what everyone
really wants is for you to get the real
story out of jj
out of uh coming out of houston so that
that'll be uh that'll be your unique
challenge
well i i will do that the minute you
give me the hardened one first
that is see what i'm saying
i i don't even say certain
i'm here to help i'm here to help and
facilitate and i look forward to
tomorrow's chat
um and i how can people you know see
this get involved or or knock on the
door to see any of this stuff
yeah if you go to mitssac.com
mit sloan sports analytics conference so
mitssac.com and
get your ticket and see jj watt and
mark cuban and demoff and everyone you
just mentioned but it's a pretty
pretty fun uh it's gonna be a pretty fun
year well i appreciate it
as always i appreciate being part of
your rolodex i'll help you out in any
way i can and i look forward to that
chat tomorrow and uh i appreciate the
time today
daryl thanks for the call thanks for
having me appreciate it it's daryl moore
everybody
president of basketball operations of
t.j
jefferson's philadelphia 76ers take that
for dad
next time we'll ask daryl about the
analytics of one human being having
19 favorite sports teams take that for
data
and the odds of winning a championship
or not having your team win a
championship
that tells you that i'm not a bandwagon
fan guys in different teams that they
claim is there
minus 10 there's nine of them hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here